how much does this thing weigh well try
and pick it up
okay which is
okay all right yeah yeah be nice to it
105
105 pounds it consists of four motors
connected up to these spinning magnet
arrays
and if you spin these fast enough it
will actually levitate that's correct
let's see if it can do it you ready
let's fire it up
it's lifting okay it's flying now
is it yeah
now it is so easy to just move around
that's amazing give it a push like it's
got some real
wow it could carry some weight hey
yeah that is amazing
so how does it work well it's similar to
how a magnet falling through a pipe is
slowed down
any time a conductor experiences a
changing magnetic field
electric currents are induced in it
which create a magnetic field to oppose
that change
and in this case the spinning magnets
induce currents in the copper sheet
they create a magnetic field which is
nearly a mirror image of the spinning
magnets and so they're repelled
if the rotors spin fast enough this
repulsion leads to levitation
and that is awesome all right let's set
it down again yep
so it's just going to come gently land
the induced currents then encounter
resistance in the copper so they
dissipate their energy as heat
whoa and this copper is
pretty hot it's gotten warmer yeah i can
still keep my hand on it at least
for a second or two but it is like uh
like a hot mug of coffee
or something yeah i experienced this
before with another electromagnetic
levitation device
except with this one the changing
magnetic field was created by an
electromagnet in the base
inducing currents in a light aluminum
plate which levitated
the plate got so hot you could boil
water on it check out how hot this plate
is
if you have two north magnets facing
each other
yeah they normally just kind of like
fall off yeah is there a similar
problem here or no uh not really no and
the reason is
the magnetic fields that are induced by
currents in the copper sheet
uh a mirror image of the applied
magnetic field um
and the effect is so quick that that as
it moves it just kind of follows it
around making this device work in
practice
is harder than it looks for one thing
the magnetic field of the permanent
magnets has to be
very strong neodymium magnets are strong
but there's a special configuration you
can use to make them even stronger
it's called a halbach array they're used
in particle accelerators they're used
in um fridge magnets actually halbach
arrays so they're stronger on the side
that sticks to the fridge
so use less material overall magnetic
field lines run from north to south
and they're normally symmetric on both
sides of a magnet but if you rearrange
them like this
the magnetic field lines are channeled
almost entirely into one
side of the magnetic array and they
cancel out on the other side
this configuration produces a much
stronger magnetic field without
changing the properties of the magnets
in these rotors there are 12
wedge-shaped magnets their magnetic
poles are fixed in this particular
arrangement
this increases the magnetic field on the
bottom side and almost eliminates it on
the top
as the magnets spin they create a
rotating magnetic field and the copper
beneath them
this induces currents that create
magnetic fields which oppose the
magnetic field of the spinning magnets
above
the result is a repulsive force that is
effectively
lift for this quadcopter but in addition
to lift there is also drag
energy is clearly being dissipated in
the system as the heat produced by the
induced currents in the copper
net energy comes from the fact the
magnetic field of the induced current is
not a perfect mirror of the spinning
magnets above
instead the induced magnetic poles are
slightly ahead
so they produce a backward force on the
rotors which is really a backwards
torque
and that's why the rotors on alternate
corners have to spin in
opposite directions because otherwise
they would produce a net spin
and turn the whole machine in one
direction this way
they cancel out this principle has been
used to achieve levitation in
everything from maglev trains to
hoverboards and
it's being considered as a means to make
the hyperloop a super fast system for
transporting people and goods
through tubes at very low pressure but
instead of spinning the magnets
the vehicle's motion itself would cause
the magnetic field to change
in the conductive track below so in the
future do you think this is going to be
how we travel
i think like ongoing developments in
digital motor controllers and
very powerful magnets will mean that
talking about moving humans and cargo at
extremely high speeds
is actually something that we can as a
species kind of look at be like wow
it turns out that getting from one city
to another city in the same day
is something that the next billion or
two billion people might have the
opportunity to do in one lifetime
hey veritasium is supported by viewers
like you on patreon
and by audible audible has an unmatched
selection of audiobooks
plus original shows news comedy and more
and for viewers of this channel they
offer a free 30-day trial of their
service just go to audible.com
veritasium now if you're looking for a
good book recommendation uh maybe you
can try out the one i'm listening to
right now
which is elon musk tesla spacex and the
quest for a fantastic future by ashley
vance
this is a biography about one of the in
my view
most impressive entrepreneurs alive
today
and this book was written by
interviewing hundreds of his employees
his acquaintances
and elon musk himself and so it provides
a really in-depth and thorough look
at that incredible determination that's
made possible
all of elon musk's ventures so if you're
intrigued by him and his work
then you should check out this book and
you can download it for free by going to
audible.com
veritasium or you can pick any other
book of your choosing for a one month
free trial
so i want to thank audible for
supporting me and i want to thank you
for watching